you know what it seems to be like have
you ever have you ever been in any way
remotely connected to the Golden Globes
no I just whenever you do a movie and
you have to go and see the Hollywood
Foreign Press the first time I have that
and I meant the hundred or so people in
the Hollywood Foreign Press I went oh I
get it
this whole [ __ ] thing is a scam the
whole [ __ ] the Oscars the Golden
Globes is all [ __ ] it's all [ __ ]
the Golden Globes I wouldn't trust these
guys to walk my dog Wow yeah believable
right and only wanted to do is run up
and get selfies with you it's crazy yeah
it's like honestly speaking to the
Hollywood Foreign Press is like and I
mean no disrespect to people in mental
hospitals it's like it's like people who
are like crazy yeah it's like when
Johnny Depp that movie that he did that
was terrible there was a Johnny Depp
movie that was nominated at the Golden
Globes
there's no absolutely terrible Mordecai
not even work I love above Chocolat
I love Chocolat was right yeah you know
what I think you must have had your
lithium Annie but he did it and a Ricky
Gervais was hosting right and he goes
you know the only reason why you know
Johnny Depp is here is because the
Foreign Press wants to take photos with
them yeah well and that's when I in my
head I'm like cuz I saw that movie yeah
that's tourists Angela know what it was
yeah that was nominated and then they
wanted Angelina and Johnny Depp back to
Golden Globes just to take like photos
and you say that Jelena like you like
your friends new friends no it's like
saying um I see Jesus in that same way
she used to live when they were together
they lived right next to my compound
their compound was next to my compound
next to Christopher Nolan's we won't
play we'll wait brad pitt and Jolie
lived next year compound he live right
in our area
Tailwaggers I did the divorce was going
on you didn't see all the helicopters
over the neighborhood that's what it was
being robbed or something it might be
nuts yeah yeah
yeah you know Wow no because we're
listen we're a little closer to
Frankland oh stop trying to be correct
yeah yeah oh man with the people we
don't live alone in this building once
that yeah we're with the people you're
with the PA yeah yeah a street
credibility that's right and you guys
are up there with the booze look I clean
my fountains just like a regular guy I
know I loved your place you know why I
love your place because you can't see
any you can't see your house yeah
from the street I'm gonna tell people
where it is obviously they can't see
anything
yeah yeah and there's a gate hmm and
there's that tall what's that guy's name
I love that guy Tomas Tomas oh there's a
foreigner there a foreigner by the to
much he is a funky East European yeah
yeah and welcome one whoa the gate opens
you walk into this compound it's [ __ ]
great
[Music]